welcome to sky studios in west london
tonight the final two candidates hoping
to be the next prime minister will face
questions from conservative party
members and from me i'm k burley this is
mr trust of course and rishi sunak as
well good evening to you both for the
next 90 minutes they'll be answering
questions from some of the people who
will decide their future this is the
battle for number 10.
good evening and welcome to the battle
for number 10 the struggle for voters
between liz trusts and rishi sunat comes
to a head tonight here at sky news for
weeks the candidates for conservative
leader have debated but only now are the
people who'll pick them finally getting
the delayed chance to vote the backdrop
a country predicted to be about to
plunge into recession it really is
make or break tonight we have more than
60 conservative members and others in
our audience largely reflecting the
demographic makeup of the party many of
them are still undecided over who to
back in a format that's different and we
hope perhaps more illuminating than
other events the two candidates will
separately face questions from the
audience and then face mine in an
extended in-depth interview we tossed a
coin before we came on air
who won
liz trust one and she chose to go first
she is with us now you're happy with the
good good evening it's nice good evening
thank you thank you
great to see you are you happy with the
format i'm very happy ready for the
first question yes exactly here we go
let's start with our first question and
that is diana who's here on the front
row good evening diana what's your
question for mr my question for liz is
the bank of england have said that a
recession is inevitable
what could you do to mitigate the impact
of this
well what the bank of england have said
today is of course extremely worrying
but it is not inevitable we can change
the outcome and we can make it more
likely that the economy grows and what's
important is first of all that we need
to help people struggling with the cost
of living i would immediately reverse
the national insurance increase i would
also
have a temporary moratorium on the green
energy level to save people money on
fuel bills but i'd also keep corporate
corporation tax low to make sure that we
are attracting investment into our
economy and doing all we can to avoid a
recession because i know what it's like
when people lose their jobs when towns
and cities across our country struggle i
don't want our country to go through
that that's why it's so important we
keep taxes low and we do all we can to
grow the economy by taking advantage of
our post-brexit freedom unleashing
investment changing things like the
procurement rules and doing things
differently but now is the time to be
bold because if we don't act now we are
headed for very very difficult times are
you happy with that i am that's good to
hear thank you okay anybody else got to
follow up on that one for us nobody at
this stage we're just warming you up
still aren't we okay well i've got one
you're confident that you'll be able to
avert a recession by the end of the year
well what we know at the moment is a
recession is predicted by the bank of
england and what we need to make sure is
we're using all the tools at our
disposal keeping taxes low doing the
reforms we need to to our economy to get
growth going faster to encourage people
to set up businesses to encourage
businesses to invest and i want us to be
on the side the people who work hard
people who do the right thing people who
support their families people who set up
businesses and that's why it's so
important we don't burden them with
excess regulation but that we also keep
taxes low under the current proposals
our corporation tax would go up to the
same level as france and 10 points ahead
of ireland and i really worry about our
capacity to attract that investment into
our economy if we do that you simply
can't tax your way to growth and i'm
afraid the very high taxes we have at
the moment a 70-year high are likely to
lead to a recession okay and that's what
the bank of england is predicting okay
neha is here neha good evening t what's
your question for miss trust uh hi liz
my question is i'm amongst very few in
my age group in ethnicity that are
actually members of the conservative
party i've been speaking to some of us
and we are afraid that the party has
lost credibility so my question is how
will you repair the damage to the
party's reputation well the most
important thing is we deliver on the
promises we made we got elected across
the country in 2019 because of our
manifesto we said we'd unleash
opportunity that we would
grow the economy that we would keep
taxes low so we need to deliver on all
of those things we need to deliver on
the opportunities of brexit and when we
promise something we need to follow
through on it i think that's really
important but i also want the
conservative party to be a party that
reaches out to everybody across the
country gets new people on board
encourages people to join our party
because we've got some fantastically
talented mps but we need a new
generation of members and i would
appoint a really strong party chairman
uh to encourage that to happen any clues
i i have not i am definitely okay not
being premature
we're still in the middle of a
leadership race and what i'm about is
about talking to our party members about
my policies for government but what i
can say is i would always make sure i
appointed people to my cabinet on the
basis of merits and people that get
things done because what people really
want us to do is deliver and we've only
got two years it's not a long amount of
time and we need to get started straight
away so i want people from all parts of
the party from all parts of the country
who can really get on and deliver okay
politicians always say that our party is
a broad church and i always point out to
them that people die in broad church
let's bring it
good evening liz
i'm a medical consultant
i work in a hospital
and i see day in day out the relentless
pressure that our medical staff is
having now understaffing is a real issue
at this moment in time if you become the
next prime minister how will you solve
this
well first of all the nhs has done a
fantastic job in covid but we are facing
a huge backlog and that is putting huge
pressure on first of all i make sure
we're putting the recent funding we
allocated the 13 billion into social
care because there are many people who
are in hospital who ought to be in
social care but there aren't the beds
available so i'd first of all make sure
we're investing the money in social care
i'd also support our doctors and nurses
more by removing some of the central
dictats and also having fewer layers of
management i've
on the campaign trail over the last few
weeks i've met people who face seven or
eight layers of management above them
and i think that can be quite difficult
and quite demotivating and what we need
is more of the
more of the empowerment more of the
decisions to be made by people on the
front line there are also a number of
other issues we need to look at like
doctors pensions i've met a lot of
doctors who've gone into retirement
because of the specific issues around
their pensions i need to sort that out
and also
there are many doctors who very kindly
came out of retirement to help during
covert you know help with the
vaccination program help with
the real issues we face in our hospitals
and what i'd like to do is see what we
can do to encourage those people to come
back into the profession and really help
because we do face serious issues it is
difficult to get a gp appointment i
represent a rural area we've got real
problems with ambulance waiting times as
well so we need all hands on deck but i
really believe that it's by trusting
people on the front line trusting the
professionals more and
making the organization a really great
place to work that we will actually
solve these problems together
i will say that i know that
people that i work with would be really
really happy if you looked into pension
tax because a lot of people are going
into early retirement exactly i'm sure
that will help bring the waiting lists
down and uh um you know help the road
for recovery as well so thank you thank
you but but we also need to listen to
people like you who are actually
involved in the health service and
listen to your advice because what what
i've heard
is lots of areas where we could use our
facilities better so for example i met a
doctor who told me that he wanted to go
in and work at the weekend use the
equipment to the weekend but actually
he'd been banned from more senior people
in the organization from doing that so
there are things like that that i think
we can empower people to do things
differently and really treat this as a
major
national program to to deal with the
aftermath of coping we were very
successful at dealing with covert
getting the vaccine rolling out the
vaccine but now we have a a major issue
with the national health service and we
need all of the best brains working on
it just clarify are you suggesting that
you should sack layers of management no
i'm not what i'm suggesting is that we
need to deploy people in the national
health service better and what i have
heard so i'll keep them there's been a
lot of there's been a lot of targets set
centrally by the department of health
and nhs england and i want things to be
decided more locally so there's less
distance between the people making the
decisions and the people actually on
front line people want to ask you
questions mr i think david from guilford
david where are you hand up david
where is he there he is he's just here
david you've got a question on ukraine i
believe i have i thought it was going to
rishi i must admit oh well
i'm i'm perfectly happy
how would you propose to broker peace
negotiations in ukraine
as opposed to continuing to provide arms
to prolong the state of war
well the only way
this war will end is when the russians
leave ukraine and we need to make sure
that we
enable the ukrainians to defeat vladimir
putin if there's any
failed peace settlement if there's any
giveaway of ukrainian territory what we
know from history is russia will just
come back for more we saw that with the
minsk accords which didn't work and we
know what vladimir putin's plans are he
said that he wants to create a greater
russia essentially the old soviet union
including the likes of the baltic states
so that is why it's so important that we
were the first european country to
supply weapons to ukraine and we need to
continue to do that but we also need to
work with our allies like the americans
who are also putting weapons into
ukraine we also need to toughen up the
sanctions on russia because at the
moment the way putin is able to fund his
appalling war machine is because of the
oil and gas revenues that he's getting
and so that means us finding alternative
sources particularly in the uk we we
have the north sea we can invest in more
nuclear but it also involves other
countries finding alternative sources as
well because what putin has done is he's
used europe's dependence on russian gas
to hold the whole continent to ransom
and that is appalling and we know the
end result of what happens when
dictators get appeased is that every
inch of um territory that's been taken
since 2014 well i certainly think it
would be wrong for us to give away
any territory on behalf of the
ukrainians now of course president
zielenski and it ultimately is the
person who has to determine what an
eventual peace deal would look like and
he has been very clear that russia needs
to leave the entirety of the ukrainian
territory but i think it'd be completely
wrong for the united kingdom or indeed
any other country
to say
ukraine should give up part of that
their territory that would be very wrong
and what i worry is the lesson it would
give to aggressors around the world
if russia was seen by saber rattling by
landing up lining up troops on the
border lining up tanks from the border
then successfully gaining a piece of
ukrainian territory what message would
that send to others around the world it
would be a terrible message and the
long-term threat to global security
would be appalling david no i just
wondered if you didn't mention anything
about attempting to negotiate or broker
some peace deal
the
uh we have been involved in working on
negotiations with our american french
and german colleagues and we are
providing support to the ukrainians to
do just that but it is ultimately about
what the ukrainians are willing to
negotiate what i don't want to see is
ukraine be put under any pressure
to give up territory for
expediency's sake because i'm saying it
simply won't be expedient because all
we'll see
is russia retreat and then come back for
more later and they still haven't given
up their ambitions to take the whole of
ukraine it was a tactical retreat away
from kiev not a long-term retreat and we
need to be very very worried about
putin's intentions it's one of the
reasons by the way that i favor raising
our defense spending to three percent of
gdp
over the next year we've got lots of
questions to get through so
not at all i want to bring in our next
question which is about housing and it's
from
jude from chippenham and i've wanted to
say this all evening hey jude
thank you very much
um hello foreign secretary i have
recently graduated and will be moving to
london to start a new job as a
commercial lawyer
when i made the decision i thought
perhaps naively that it would make sense
to buy somewhere in london rather than
rent
but that was before i saw the cost of a
deposit on a starter home
how will you
solve the housing crisis and make it
easier for young people to own their own
home
jude i think it's incredibly important
that we help more people get on the
housing ladder it is a problem that this
generation of young people
end up buying houses much later in their
lives than previous generations
but the way to do it is not the system
we have at the moment which is
soviet-style top-down housing targets
which simply
cause huge concern and don't actually
deliver the results we want and i've
before i became an mp i was a counselor
i sat on a planning committee it was
hours of my life i'll never get back
because
because
we didn't have any control over what
happened
everything got overruled by the planning
and spectra in bristol so what i want is
a much more localized system of planning
so in london for example i think there's
more opportunity to build up uh in
london uh to build more
higher story buildings i think in other
parts of the country what we need is
more
investment zones where we have
industry developed alongside homes
alongside infrastructure and that can be
determined by local people
but the one-size-fits-all planning
system we have at the moment simply
doesn't work the other thing i do to
help you specifically
is when somebody does rent they should
be able to use their rental history
towards getting a mortgage for their
home and that will help people who are
long-term rental renters get onto the
housing ladder okay just want to share
this quote with you um that you i think
it was three years ago perhaps a little
bit longer we need to build a million
homes on the london green belt near
railway stations and around other
growing cities specifically to allow the
under 40s to be able to own their own
homes do you still want to build a
million homes on green belt and the
night so what i don't want to do okay
is build it on the green belt
because i do think well i've changed
i've changed my view on that i'm still
very keen for the under 40s to be able
to aim their own homes but what i've
seen
is that the way these top-down targets
have resulted in having the opposite
effect of getting the homes built and
i'm now of the view that what we need to
do is have incentives
to get local councils to
set up investment zones and do things
differently because the current system
isn't working okay so you've changed
your mind on that one uh jill from
tonbridge wells are you angry jill
just about disgusted
hi hi liz hi
how important is it to balance the books
so the answer is it is important over
the long term to make sure that the
private sector is growing faster than
the public sector and we were able to
generate the revenues for our economy
and also be able to pay for our public
services but it isn't right to try and
balance the book straight away when
we've had a major global crisis like
covid and every single country in the
world has built up debts from that
crisis and in fact we have lower levels
of debt than most of the g7 countries so
i think trying to balance the books
prematurely is actually
counterproductive because if you put up
taxes and you stop businesses forming
you stop new investment and you stop
economic growth you're less likely to be
able to pay down the debt over the
longer term
happy with that no it doesn't look as
though you vote so what's your follow-up
question on that one liz i do not want
to see my children
and my grandchildren encumbered with
huge debt at a time of rising interest
rates bank of england today and at a
time of high inflation the one thing
margaret thatcher believed in was sound
money this is not sound economics and
the whole business about economic growth
tax cuts do not necessarily produce
economic growth if you look at germany
for example it has much higher
corporation tax than we have and indeed
even with the rises that are in the
pipeline and yet their economy is not
tanking in the way that ours is tanking
so i think this is this question of
balancing the books is really
fundamental signed by sources and
economics well
we we have lower levels of debt
than countries like the us
canada and japan so it's simply not true
to say that we have particularly high
national debt at the moment but what i
do know
is that families across the country are
struggling to pay their bills and what i
would do is help
interest rates liz i remember those days
i had to pay a mortgage of 15 are we
going back to that level again no
because we've got an independent bank of
england that make decisions about
interest rates and we're that we're
we're nowhere near uh that's that
position at all
but
to say
that we are going to put up taxes to the
highest level and beyond the highest
level in 70 years and we think there
will be no consequences for economic
growth i'm afraid i think that's wrong
and i speak to lots of companies lots of
businesses who are very concerned about
the proposals to raise corporation tax
they're very concerned about the level
of interest rates they're very concerned
about the regulations on their
businesses at the moment the fact is
that britain has got less competitive
relative to other countries under these
corporation tax proposals we would have
corporation tax that is 10 points higher
than ireland yeah and it will make us
less competitive germany and you don't
get germany well germany has a very very
different economic system from the uk
okay we've got one time for one more
question tom from gateshead where's
charm we'll come back to the quest tom
hi sorry hi thanks very much liz why did
you announce a well-researched and fully
costed policy in which you openly said
you valued the work of teachers nurses
and police officers in newcastle where i
work
less than you value those in guilford
for example
we're having this election because of
poor judgment and trust
why should we trust your judgment
well the reason that i
immediately
decided not to pursue that policy
is it was being misinterpreted in fact
in exactly the way you said
because it wasn't about teachers or
nurses or doctors and
immediately as there were concerns
expressed about this policy
i said we're not going ahead with it and
i do think in politics there are times
when you have to
make judgments about what is right and
you have to be honest with the public
and i was very honest about the
situation it wasn't a core part of my
policy plan but i'd rather be up front
and if there's a problem make a decision
and deal it with it straight away and i
think you can see in my time as foreign
secretary in my time as trade secretary
i've been completely upfront about
everything i've done i've explained why
i've done it i've explained when there
is a change why there is a change and
that's the approach i would take as
prime minister
so that the press release didn't say
that it said that it would be um it in
order to reach the 8.8 billion in
savings that it would be expanded out
beyond civil service uh beyond the civil
service itself um so that's a mistake
will you apologize because it was
actually quite offensive
well i have been very clear
that i will not go ahead with this
policy
and that i have made a decision to do
that straight away and i've been up
front about that i don't think there is
anything to be ashamed of of saying
publicly that
this is not working as i wanted it to
work and therefore i have changed the
position on it and i'm not going ahead
with it okay this gentleman had a view
on that just wait for your microphone so
can we just get a microphone down here
thank you you were shaking your head sir
i did yeah i hate this um
apologize you know for
everything that you might have said i
just don't really don't understand it
the the oppositional was asking uh other
politicians to apologize for what they
may or may not have done
uh and it really doesn't sit well with
me when somebody's asking for your vote
you don't expect to be offended
well
simply what's that supposed to mean but
you know well i won't wait
we are going into very very difficult
times as a country yeah and we've just
talked about that
and we need somebody leading this
country who is prepared to make
decisions who is prepared to deal with
issues as they arise and is prepared to
be up front with the public okay and i
think i've demonstrated that in
everything i've done in all of the jobs
i've held okay during this campaign okay
i'll come back to you madam if i may if
you take a seat please miss trust it's
time
for my go everybody ready here we are
glass of water i wanted to pick up
actually uh just where we'd left off
there on on what the gentleman was
asking you um about on this press
release we do want we just want to
bottom it out so we know exactly where
we are
you said
that public sector pay policy has been
misrepresented by the media
here's the proposal that you released
introduce regional pay boards tailoring
pay to the cost of living where civil
servants actually work saving up to 8.8
billion pounds per year so how have we
misrepresented you so far well what what
i am clear about
is that policy was not about teachers
and doctors but can i be clear kay
that i'm not going ahead with this you
can't but you said you were because i'm
just clarifying because because of the
concerns that have been expressed okay
and when something is just clarified
when there's an issue okay i deal with
it okay but just to clarify whether you
were misrepresented or not you
highlighted a very specific saving 8.8
billion pounds how did you reach that
figure
well i don't have the details and i do
think discussing a policy that i'm not
prepared
obviously these people it's it's very
pressing for these people and certainly
some of them so we just want to bottom
it out and then we're definitely there
and i'm sure you won't have to answer
these questions again it's exactly the
same figure the 8.8 billion that was
issued by the taxpayers alliance they
say regional based pay could allow
private sector salaries to catch up with
the public sector this can be done by
freezing or reducing pay for existing
roles and new positions in other words
pay cut for nurses doctors firemen
police officers in less affluent areas
which is what this gentleman was saying
that wasn't what you were proposing
you've changed absolutely that was not
my intention but given the concern that
was caused i took an immediate decision
not to proceed with this policy okay
i am somebody
who immediately
if there are issues of concern and those
are
not delivering what i want to deliver
i will
make a decision to do the right thing
and that's what i've done not just this
gentleman here but van houchen the
conservative mayor of teas valley said
there's no way you can do this without a
massive pay cut for five and a half
million people including nurses police
officers and our armed forces outside of
london
do you accept
that you made a mistake by announcing
the policy
i do accept that the way the policy
has been interpreted to cover those
people
was not right and that's why i took an
immediate decision not to go ahead with
it you offended people though you
misread the mood you accept that it was
a mistake
what i've said is i absolutely accept
that it wasn't the right policy to deal
with this situation and therefore i
withdrew the policy immediately and i'm
somebody who is honest and up front k
i dealt with the issue immediately after
the concerns were expressed about how
this policy had been interpreted and
i've dealt with it straight away okay it
was a mistake though well as i've said
i've withdrawn the policy we're not
going ahead with the policy so therefore
you know
the the points you're making are about a
policy that isn't happening no no what
i'm saying is should good leaders own
their mistakes
um or should they blame others
i'm not blaming you blaming anybody else
i'm not i'm not i'm saying that um the
policy has been misrepresented by
various people but what i don't want at
this time when people are struggling
with the cost of living is to concern
people with this policy which isn't a
core part of my policy platform and i'm
not going ahead with it okay let's talk
about the economy as we've moved on to
that um i want to talk to you about your
plans to help the worst off if i may
we've spoken to selena she's a single
mom in the northeast of england she
works part-time to support her three
children and earns just over ten
thousand pounds a year
what will you do to help her
when her energy bills reach 500 pounds a
month in january so first of all i'll
take immediate action to reverse the
national insurance rise and help won't
help her she earns less than twelve
thousand five hundred and seventy pounds
so she will she won't but also the greed
energy levy will be taking that's 150
pounds and her and so that's a drop in
the bucket really isn't it and what i
really want nine days of energy for her
and what i will also do
is work to increase the amount of
supplies we're getting out of the north
sea so that we can get more gas into our
system so we can move forward on dealing
with the energy crisis and energy
security because ultimately
ultimately
these problems can only be dealt with by
first of all making sure putin
is defeated by the ukrainians so that we
don't have this energy supply problem
and also
by releasing more reserves in the north
sea i'm also in favor of fracking in
areas that support it so we get more of
our own domestic energy supply but what
i can assure you kay
is i will do all i can to help people
who are struggling with the cost of
living i understand that people are
going through difficult times and if
there are any more available resources
of course i would put that to helping
people with the cost of living let me
tell you absolutely if i'm okay these
are selena's words i'm really worried
about how i'm going to keep my children
warm and fed this is going to cost lives
if they don't do something now
but this is why it's so very important
that we offer
support to businesses
that we it's not going to help her well
it will help her because
the real danger we're in as a country
and this is what the bank of england has
said today is we're facing a recession
and what a recession would mean is
people losing their jobs businesses
going out of business people struggling
across the country so that's why it's so
important we do things like keeping
corporation tax slow keeping personal
taxes as low as possible
getting
getting things like infrastructure
projects done quicker to grow the
economy that is ultimately the way we
are going to deal with this crisis is
through economic growth okay here's an
idea what about the windfall tax shell
posted profits of 9.3 billion pounds
between april
and june if we put that another way
shell made 1 190 pounds per second so
since i started this sentence they've
made 17 000 pounds in profit why don't
we have another win full tax well the
problem with a windfall tax
is that it might secure money in the
short term but what it does is it puts
off companies investing in britain in
the long term because they think that
they wouldn't they think at any point
they could be taxed and i think that is
a problem what we need to show is
britain's open for business we're a
country that keeps to our word of what
our taxes are and winful taxes are
essentially surprise taxes that
companies don't know that are happening
what i would do instead k
is make sure we're incentivizing the
likes of shell to be
releasing more resources from the north
sea to actually help the problem that we
face which is a lack of energy supply
the head of bp said that he would
continue to his business would continue
to invest if there was another winfield
it's not just bp though it's the signal
that it sends to every business across
the country that the government is
willing to give you a surprise tax and i
think that is a problem for britain i've
already talked about how our corporation
tax rate is uncompetitive compared to
other countries if we also have a
reputation for levying a surprise tax on
any industry that makes a profit that is
a big problem for our country shell is
giving their um shareholders 6.5 billion
pounds
people at home watching who can't afford
to um heat their homes
come the winter will be horrified at
that
look at who these shareholders are these
shareholders are often people with
pensions in a pension funds you know
shareholders are not you know all sort
of men in sitting sitting in offices you
know
there is a real
there's no such thing as free money
and i just think we've got to be very
careful if the uk gets a reputation for
arbitrarily taking money and tax that
we've not sort of done through the
official tax system i think that's a
problem okay let's move on to foreign
affairs we've talked about it a little
bit do you want a sip of water you're
very welcome um talking about taiwan i'm
sure that we've all seen haven't we
what's been happening
in taiwan over the last few days
um as foreign secretary you told the
select committee last month that we
should have armed ukraine earlier should
we arm taiwan no
well what we do need to make sure
is that democracies like taiwan are
defended
and yesterday i put out a statement with
my fellow g7 foreign ministers about the
very difficult situation in taiwan and
concern about the rhetoric that we're
hearing from china the escalatory
rhetoric of course we have a very
uh a very secure
control system for exports in the united
kingdom and we do license exports to
taiwan
at the moment
exports that are provided by the private
sector so should we arm them or not well
what i'm saying is we already license
equipment to go to taiwan okay and
there's a long-standing policy of the uk
government to do that okay you said uh
to the foreign affairs select committee
in june uh month before last we should
have done things early we should have
been supplying the defensive weapons
into ukraine earlier we need to learn
that that lesson for taiwan every piece
of equipment we have sent takes months
of a training so the sooner we do that
the better so just to clarify we do
license um arms that go there but that
is that is as far as we're going to go
at this stage
yes
that is as far as we will go at this
stage but we are working with our allies
very closely on this because there are
countries like the united states japan
okay who
also
are extremely concerned about the future
of taiwan okay and what we need to do is
work collectively and i have championed
the g7 acting together as an economic
nato to challenge some of china's
economic coercion practices but also to
make sure we're looking at the security
situation and making sure democracies
like taiwan are protected i'm sure you
can understand kay that i can't go into
every detail of those conversations on
but it's a it's a very important
principle that we do not allow
aggressors to
to invade you know democratic democratic
places we've seen nancy pelosi another
strong influential woman in taiwan this
week uh will you visit taiwan if you're
prime minister
uh
we we currently have a long standing yes
or no really no
we we we have a long-standing position
that the foreign secretary the ministry
of defense and the prime minister i
don't visit thailand let me talk to you
about uh ukraine was it an era of
judgment to say you'd support brits
going to fight in ukraine what i was
very clear about is that i supported the
cause
of the fight in ukraine but i've always
been clear
that the travel advice is that british
people should not go to ukraine no what
you said was i do support that when
zielenski called for international
volunteers ukrainians are fighting for
freedom not just for ukraine but the
whole of europe and you did support
people you did support brits going to
ukraine to fight well what i suppose you
have to be correct what are your own
defenses what i was saying
is that i supported the cause in ukraine
okay your foreign office website said
brits traveling to fight in ukraine
could be committing an act of terrorism
did you know that when you said it
well what what i've said is that i
support the cause in ukraine and
actually i've done a lot of work to
support british citizens who have been
detained in ukraine who've been there in
the long term and the foreign office has
provided those people are you sorry that
people misinterpreted what you were
saying
well what i have said is that the
defense the advice was very clear the
travel advice was very clear and i
announced that publicly that people
shouldn't go to ukraine but i think what
is happening here because we speak about
poland who were going into ukraine who
were brits that had crossed the border
and were then subsequently going into
ukraine well many you know there have
been many british people going into
ukraine okay during the war but we are
very clear about our travel okay i've
got some quick fire questions for you if
i may here we go in your first meeting
with the queen will you apologize for
wanting to abolish the monarchy well
i've already
i've already met the queen and she's
been far too polite to raise that issue
with me and i will not be uh i will not
be raising it with her okay but if she
did would you apologize
well i was wrong uh i was wrong to say
what i did at the time okay will you be
apologizing to the first minister of
scotland when you see her
no i won't
uh what's the naughtiest thing you've
ever done i'm certainly i'm certainly
not going to say that on tv oh is it
that naughty
well my daughters are watching so i
don't want to i don't want them getting
any ideas okay yeah
being prime minister is the most
invasive um exposed period in any
politician's life is there anything that
you feel that you would want to come
clean with the audience here in the
studio and at home because there's no
one else listening so it's all fine i
can just tell anything that you need to
get off your chest there are i can tell
you okay there are no skeletons in my
closet i think everything i've ever said
and done is known about very publicly
would you remove the whip from boris
johnson if he's found to have
deliberately misled parliament over
partygate
um i'm not making any prejudgments about
that why not well i'm just i'm not
making prejudgments i'll see what the
committee says but if they say
deliberately misled parliament as i say
i mean i'm i'm not making any
prejudgments about that okay what one
change by the way i'm very clear he
didn't mislead parliament well we'll see
what the uh business what the committee
says what one change to the system
would you make to restore
integrity because there's a lot of
people here in the studio
thank you
uh not just here in the studio but
watching at home as well you know
integrity has been lost in the
westminster bubble what would you do to
change it well i think the the answer to
restoring integrity isn't introducing
more rules because we have endless rules
and codes the issue is about clarity
and leadership and doing what you say
you will do and following through on
your promises what i would also do as
prime minister is restore the chief whip
to number 12 downing street the chief
whip was moved out by alistair campbell
and replaced with the press office i
think that was a mistake because it
reduced the link between the prime
minister the chief whip and the
parliamentary party and i would make
sure
i i would make sure we had zero
tolerance for
bad behavior in the parliamentary party
but we're also supporting mps because as
you say you know being prime minister is
an exposed job but actually being an mp
at the moment is pretty difficult you
know there's all kinds of difficult
things said about you on social media
and it can be very difficult for
people's family lives so at the same
time as making sure we have discipline
and you know making sure people are
honest and behave themselves we also do
need to offer mps that welfare and a new
ethics advisor
and you stand by if you would a new
ethics advisor well i will i will look
at the role of the
ethics advisor but
i'm somebody who
does act with integrity and i think
people have seen that in every job i've
done and i slightly worry about
outsourcing ethics to somebody else
as prime minister
i should know
the difference between
right and wrong and of course there need
to be proper independent complaints
procedure there needs to be proper
whistle-blowing procedures but i would
want to look at how how those things are
structured okay you were loyal to the pm
despite parties during lockdown
or when he promoted a man who groped
colleagues
or when he was rewriting the rules to
help out his mates um throughout that
you stood
shoulder to shoulder with a man who has
betrayed the office of prime minister i
don't agree with that characterization
kay
i supported i supported boris johnson
for the leadership i think he did a good
job as our prime minister he delivered
brexit he delivered the vaccines he also
did a fantastic job of leading the free
world in standing up to vladimir putin
in ukraine yes he made mistakes that's
absolutely true you know he he said
sorry
for the mistakes he made but i think
it's completely wrong to characterize
him in that way
i don't know what does the audience
think
hear him
yeah a great agreed agreed no no no
okay
i think it's opinion opinion is divided
on that issue i think we can hear we can
hear from from people in the audience
but i have worked closely with boris
johnson i know the difficult times he
went to you know he was in very serious
trouble uh when he had covered and you
know it's been a very very difficult
time to be in government but look you
know many mistakes were made during
lockdown okay um you know by by many
people and i just think to sort of say
that
this was the
you know crowning problem is it is not
right yeah so i'm in charge of policy
some not a final question for you just
before we let you go you were a remainer
and now you're not you supported uh
brits to fight in ukraine and you didn't
you wanted to build on the green belt
and now you don't you wanted to abolish
the monarchy and now you don't you
wanted to arm taiwan and now i'm not
sure if you're saying whether you do or
not you wanted civilization so we do
provide okay with those you wanted to
cut civil servants pay in the regions
and then you said you didn't
will the
real
liz trust please stand up
okay i i'm somebody who
you know i didn't come from a
traditional conservative background
my first political experience was going
on a cnd march with my mother age seven
you know i then
uh as a teenager joined the liberal
democrats i'm not sure how much i should
be held to account for things i said
when i was 18 or 19. but i've always had
a belief
that
we can be
a more successful country that people
should be able to control their own
lives i've always believed in the
principle of freedom i've always
believed in low taxation yes
my views on other issues have developed
over time but show me somebody who has
the same views at 19 and 49 and i'll
show you somebody who's not capable of
original thoughts so yes you know i have
i have you know developed my views i've
considered things differently and i also
listen to people okay and i think that's
important so what we've been talking
about today we have to give the policy
as i've given you the same amount of
time i did say well the real this trust
please stand up you're still sitting
down
that's just because you're trying to get
rid of me
please thank you very much thank you
thank you thank you so go with us one
second
let's get some reaction from the
audience should we gentlemen over here i
heard um who was uh shouting out
gentlemen here yep boom there sir go on
i was gonna say um liz mentioned about
nothing in her closet she mentioned
about integrity does that mean at some
point in the future she's proved to have
lied about something she's gonna resign
i don't know what do you think that's
what i wanted mosca
who else has got a question the lady
here had a hand up earlier yes madam um
i was just wanting to ask if she
actually believed that boris johnson's
actions had damaged the conservative
party and their chances in the next
general election okay
great question have you you obviously
all mostly are in fact all of you are
going to be people that will be voting
for our next prime minister have you
received your ballot papers yet no no
you still haven't received them you have
one person but most people haven't okay
well
obviously we're moving on to the next
section now of our program you'll be
able to hear what mr sunic thinks and
then we're going to ask you what you
think how does that sound ladies and
gentlemen rishi sooner
hi hi
brilliant
so we're going to do exactly the same as
we did with lift cross is that okay
we're going to start with the questions
from the audience and then i've got some
questions for you as well if that's okay
here we go let's start our first
question uh with matthew
matthew from kent there he is in the
middle there matthew thank you
is there a point that you would stand
aside in this campaign mr sunak given
opinion polls are pointing to a dominant
mistrust win
and also we're seeing daily declarations
from big tory big guns uh in her favor
well thanks for the question matthew and
the quick answer is no
and that's because well thank you
and you know what that's that's because
i'm fighting for something i really
believe in and i'm taking my ideas
around the country i'm talking to all of
you our members across the country about
what i think is best for our country at
a really difficult time and i want to
have that debate with people because i
passionately believe what i'm saying is
right i want to convince as many people
of that as possible and hopefully i can
do that with you all tonight but you
talk about big guns i mean i've also had
in the mp phase of this in parliament
the most number of mps support me not
just in the first round but in every
round since you talk about big guns
coming out i just had nigel lawson this
morning margaret thatcher's chancellor
supporting my approach to the economy
michael howard a former leader of our
party just introduced me at a hustings
yesterday william hague another leader
of our party my predecessor in richmond
and north yorkshire all supporting my
candidacy so look i think i've got lots
of support but i'm going to fight
incredibly hard till the last day of
this campaign for each and every one of
your votes the stakes are really high
i'm passionate what i believe in and i
want to try and convince you all that
i'm right anybody else that's going to
support mr sunup
i'll get a few you're all very quiet
though so you've got a question uh yes
hi um now i've been a tory for the last
30 years and i did stand for parliament
in 2005. now have been absolutely
disgusted with the
level of disunity within the tory party
so yes i'll be supporting you uh but
once you if you do become prime minister
how will you ensure that you unite the
tory party so that we can win the next
general election yeah no i'm so glad you
are so it's a really important point
because i think i think how we select
this audience we're on the same team
right we're all part of the same
conservative family and we are going to
need to come back together afterwards
and look i think you can take some
comfort from the fact that not only do i
have the most support of mps in
parliament that support is drawn from
every bit of our parliamentary party
people in the north mps in the south mps
have voted remain mps who voted leave
experienced colleagues the likes of
which we just talked about matthew's
question but brand new mps as well mps
in rural areas and urban areas so that's
the breadth of my support because that's
the kind of person i am that i could i
can build a broad team around me and
that's what i'm going to do in
government i want to make sure that we
have a government that represents all
the talents and traditions of our
amazing party and you saw some of that
on display in this leadership election
early on i want all of you to be able to
look up the government and feel a piece
of your view of conservatism represented
that's how we're going to bring people
back together because we all know in
this room the enemy is not me or liz or
anyone else our real opposition is
kirstarma in the labour party and i'm
the person who can take the fight to
them and win the next election for all
of us because that's what we all want to
see isn't it
um
actually that's a similar question to
andrew from west london where's andrew
andrew i'm over here you're over there
as well andrew were you happy with that
response
well
sort of but yeah i think
i think historically we have to look at
the fact that parties that are divided
do not win elections we are two years
out less than two years out from a
general election
what specifics can we do what specifics
can you do
to reunite the party
well well andrew you're right we are
only a couple years out from a general
election and that's why getting on with
the job as quickly as possible is really
important we don't have time to waste so
it starts day one with building that
team that i talked about that does bring
people back together around the cabinet
table and across government no more
factions no more who supported who in
the leadership contest we have to put
all that aside the moment this contests
end and start looking forward and start
delivering for the british people we've
got real challenges and i'm sure we're
going to get to talk about the economy
in a minute but that's the number one
challenge we've got to get the nhs
backlogs down we've got to get to grips
with illegal migration we've got to make
sure that we provide more energy for us
all at home there's lots of challenges
we've got and we need to get on and do
them fast so if we've got a brand new
team united in purpose to deliver for
the british people and focus on the
prize of winning the next election i
think that will galvanize minds i'm the
person that can bring people together
and lead us to that victory so okay can
i come back very quickly if you wouldn't
mind so so how many people in the
current cabinet would you have in your
cabinet okay well andrew i wouldn't i
don't think you'd expect me to answer
that a it's premature as we heard from
the first question i've got a lot of
work to do in this campaign and i'm
going to fight for every vote and that's
what i'm focused on right now but i will
tell you i will build a team that
reflects the talents and traditions of
our entire party okay the ones that's
what you will be able to look up at my
government okay and see yourself and
everyone else reflecting okay claire
from solid hall claire okay hi there hi
hi
so the my question is the
hi uh the security of this country
worries me greatly with all the sober
rattling from russia china iran and
north korea
so if you become pm will you commit to
increasing the size and budget of our
armed forces to make this country once
again a force to be reckoned with
yes claire that the simple answer is
absolutely and i don't want to say once
again because i think we are already a
force to be reckoned with an amazing
country that projects our values and our
influence around the world supporting
our allies so i don't think we have to
think that we're not we already are but
it's always more we can do now remember
i was the chancellor who oversaw the
largest increase in the defense budget
since the end of the cold war that's my
track record and actually i singled out
the ministry of defense in the middle of
the pandemic for a special treatment
because they were going through a period
where they were looking at future
threats they needed the certainty of
knowing that they had the funding to
make all those investments and the new
technologies that would keep us safe
that's why i gave them special treatment
that's not what the prime minister said
he said that you had to be actually ben
wallace said the prime minister had to
overrule you uh no that's not right we
actually do all right
i'm not going to talk of any of my
colleagues but ultimately i'm the
chancellor that's responsible for the
decisions on how we spend our money and
that's what i did right but you don't
have to take my my word for it there
when it came to ukraine what else did we
do i managed to find 2 billion pounds
from across government to send to
ukraine to support them so we can help
them and protect our values and stand up
to russian aggression but what i'm not
going to do is stand here and give you
an arbitrary target and i i know that's
what liz has said in this campaign and i
don't believe in that i don't think
that's the right response to defense
spending i don't believe in arbitrary
targets i believe in taking a threat
based approach i believe in looking at
the threats we face and then allocating
spending accordingly so i can commit to
you claire is this i will tell you i
will invest whatever it takes to keep
you and everyone else in our country
safe because that is the first duty of a
prime minister and it's certainly the
first duty of a conservative prime
minister follow up from this lady here
just wait for the microphone madam if
you would there we go thank you you were
also the chancellor that introduced eat
out to dine out
at a cost of 850 million pounds and
according to the university of warwick
that was responsible for an increase of
nuclear cases of between eight and 17
percent
well actually that's one study that said
that and i don't think it's right and it
doesn't explain the fact that in almost
any every other country around europe
everyone else experienced another wave
of covid and they didn't all have the
same policy so it's a bit odd to blame
that policy for an increase in covert
cases when that happened across europe
and indeed across most of the world but
i'll tell you what i was thinking at
that moment what i was looking at was a
situation where we had hundreds of
thousands of largely small hospitality
businesses that were on the brink of
bankruptcy because in this country
everyone was so scared and all the
evidence said that no one was going to
go back out again and in an economy like
ours that would have been disastrous and
you know what's worse two million people
work in all those small businesses and
those two million people are
disproportionately young
they're women they're working part-time
they're people who are coming off
unemployment benefit into work so as a
matter of social justice i wanted to
protect those jobs those families
livelihoods that's why i did it and
everywhere i go in this campaign across
the country i have people who come up to
me and say thank you for that because it
saved our business and it saved those
jobs
edmonds i'm right behind you okay there
we go i'm all behind everything
that sounded funny i'm so sorry i'm a
town councillor for various edmonds oh
brilliant thank you and we lost our
kings road nhs dentist they were
brilliant that was in 2018. now some of
us are going around talking like tube
stations mind the gap mind the gap what
can be done it's
2022 we need nhs dentistry because
frankly a lot of us cannot afford to go
private and we have fantastic private
dentists presents but we need our nhs
back what can you do how soon can you do
it that's the problem i'm running out of
teeth what happened to your teeth
what happened to your teeth i lost them
oh goodness yes yeah we're getting we're
getting an actual view right now with
the camera in your mouth
we're actually trying to say i have
seven fillings and and that's because i
drank an enormous amount of coke when i
was a youngster so i know i feel your
pain and we do need good dentistry and
look the nhs first of all is everyone's
number one public service priority and i
grew up in an nhs household you may have
heard on this campaign my dad he never
mentions it
just checking you never know right you
know my mum ran a chemist where i grew
up so i spent my time working in that i
understand how important especially
primary care is but look you know if
we're going to get to grips with this
and make sure that there is money for
nhs dentistry we just have to be bolder
about reforming the nhs to get more
efficiency out of it now i'm someone who
you can absolutely trust with the nhs
i'm someone who did something quite
difficult and that's create a new
funding stream to support not just the
nhs but social care because it does
start with putting more resources in to
help recover from the pandemic was an
easy thing for me to do lots of people
are upset with me about it but i believe
it was the right thing for the country
the right thing to support our fantastic
nhs doctors and nurses but money's not
enough we need to reform things so we
can get more efficiency and invest in
things like dentistry i'll give you one
example of something that i'm prepared
to do which is a bit bold it is a bit
radical and not everyone will love it
but i want to show you that i'm going to
bring some change and that's tackling
missed appointments now we have over 10
million missed appointments every year
and it's not just gps it's in hospitals
at the same time we've got lots of
people sitting there anxiously waiting
for treatment and i've said that's not
acceptable so we need to be tougher on
missed appointments because if we are
then if people can cancel them in
advance properly we free up all that
extra capacity and none of us have had
to pay an extra penny in taxes to do
that how is that workable though thank
you
how's that workable what about people
who can't afford to pay the 10 pounds
and they miss the so they can't pay to
afford to pay their fine um do they not
get treatment in future what happens
well actually okay as i said it you
don't have to do it people's first myst
it can be for people who missed a second
appointment because there are just so
many that there's a lot of space in the
system and i do think it's right to
actually say hang on we believe in an
nhs that's free at the point of use but
it's not free at the point of misuse and
when people don't show up for
appointments they are depriving other
people of treatment that they need so
there's someone equally vulnerable
waiting there sitting on a waiting list
waiting to see their consultant or their
gp and they're not getting that chance
because someone else has just not
bothered to show up and that's not all
right and look there will be some people
like you who say oh gosh maybe we
shouldn't do that but if we're not
prepared to be it's the lancet saying if
we're not prepared
that miss their appointments for all
sorts of reasons you can be
compassionate first time but at the end
of the day if we all want to cut taxes
in this country if we want to find money
to spend more on dentistry we have to be
prepared to do things differently
challenge the system and that's what i'm
prepared to do because i want to have
great healthcare i want to have great
dentistry for you and for my future
feelings but i do want to be able to cut
your taxes too we're only going to be
able to do that if we're going to reform
things and do things differently that's
the kind of prime minister i'm going to
be
it can only be compassionate once um
jeff from devon jeff where are we jack
hey jeff oh you're all over here today
hi is it jeff what was it yes trisha yes
sir hi hi um given the problems we've
had with borders control and obviously
the massive controversy with the rwanda
policy what's your plan to
um cut illegal channel crossings yes
great question and something i've been
talking a lot about over the last couple
of weeks look you know i'm the product
of this country's extraordinarily
compassionate approach to welcoming
immigrants to our shores my family are
beneficiary of that probably others in
the audience and it's something that we
should all feel really proud of it's
something that britain is amazing at and
even most recently ukraine hong kong
syria afghanistan we showed our
compassion but it is also absolutely
right that we have control over our
borders because all the people i just
mentioned came here legally and what is
not right is for people to break the
rules and come here illegally the scenes
we see on our tv screens and small boat
crossings are wrong and they need to
stop and i'm prepared again to do some
different things to be bold and radical
to stop them there's a 10 point plan on
my website with a video so you please go
and have a look at that tonight and
anyone else that's interested in this
topic i'll give you two examples of
things i'm prepared to do now one is we
need to change the definition of asylum
and move away from this european
definition which has become very broad
it's exploited by lefty lawyers and
means it's very hard to remove people i
suggest moving to a different definition
another legal standard internationally
used by i think the australians and
others and that is a much tighter
definition and will allow us to reject
more people so that's one thing we can
do the second thing is we've got to get
smarter about our foreign policy at the
moment we'll happily talk to a country
and talk about the trade deal we're
going to give them
and maybe even the aid that we're going
to send that country but we don't then
also say hang on you have to take back
your failed asylum seekers well that's
not right we should be more joined up we
should be tougher about that so that's
just two of the things in my 10-point
plan but fundamentally we must get a
grip of this we have to make the rwanda
policy work i will do whatever it takes
including legal changes if required to
make it work so we get control of our
borders although we're a compassionate
country and we'll always be it's
entirely right and many of us vote for
brexit for this reason that we are in
control of who's coming here that's a
simple thing and i will deliver it as pm
okay
applause on that one gentleman there
really quickly because we need to move
on if we can just stretch over with the
microphone for you sir there we go your
question really quickly so we currently
have a point-based immigration system
do you propose any changes or are you
happy to keep it as is this
so look on immigration look for we have
to tackle this question of illegal
jeff's question on illegal migration we
shall tackle that robustly and radically
so that's part one now with the rest of
immigration right there's a couple of
things i i want to be pragmatic about
this so i want to make sure that we're
also supporting our economy to grow
and that means having an immigration
system that actually welcomes the best
and the brightest from around the world
because if we want to grow our economy
if we want people here who are going to
set up companies of the future who are
going to come and research in our
universities who are going to come and
work at some of our fastest growing
companies actually we want to have a
visa regime that makes with us the best
place in the world for all those people
to come i started reforming the system
as chancellor and as prime minister i
want to finish the job so that the best
and the brightest wherever they are
around the world america india brazil
wherever they think huh the uk is the
place i want to come because if we can
attract them here it's going to be good
for all of us it's going to be good for
the economy and that's something that i
want to deliver okay we've got a
question from alexander on trust
alexander you've got a question
hi alexander yeah good to see you buddy
uh what does honesty mean to you in
politics and
leadership
great question
honestly in a sense it means telling you
the truth right and even when that's not
easy and i think you can see in this
leadership election
that's what i'm doing right and that
first question at the beginning of how
i'm doing in the polls and all of that
right i am saying some things that are
maybe not the easiest thing in the world
to hear i'm not sitting here or standing
here promising you tens and tens of
billions of pounds of goodies straight
away because i don't think that's the
right thing to do for our economy i
think it's risky i think it risks making
the inflation problem far worse and
costing you all far more and you know
what my life would be far easier if i
wasn't saying that right but i want to
be honest with you i want to be straight
with a country about the challenges we
face and what is going to be required to
fix them and that's why i think you can
trust me on this because i'm prepared to
do that even though it's going to cost
me politically
at two mr sunac
though at two mr sunak we've seen the
images of what you were allegedly uh the
the uh nadine doris i think it was who
came up with this i don't know has
anybody seen it stan stabbing you in the
back i mean how do you respond to that
sorry kate what are you well my point is
we're talking about trust you can't be
trusted
uh what what which means
you unite in boris for your own interest
that's there you go
right perfect right okay let's let's
address that actually great that you've
raised it so what was your name sir
stephen right so yes i worked with the
prime minister for a couple of years and
i'm really proud of the work we achieved
together actually and i think he
deserves enormous credit for what he
achieved during that time and i as i
said i'm proud to have been a part of it
and he gave me the job i had and i'm
grateful to him for it but it got to a
point where it was too difficult for me
to stay now we had well documented
differences of opinion on economic
policy as you can see in this leadership
campaign by the way and it's simply
impossible
for a chancellor and prime minister not
to be on the same page when it comes to
economic policy that doesn't make sense
and and there's no way that can work so
of course i had no choice but to go but
also
it came to a point where the government
was on the wrong side
of an ethical problem that i could not
defend and enough was enough for me but
it wasn't just me it was 60 other
members of parliament all left the
government
at the same time because for them enough
was enough okay and that's why we're
here because we need to change things in
december last year did they rishi you
you've been campaigning for a long time
and it was perfectly timed a cynical
motivation to try and get you into
number ten no that's just
simply not true so i was due to give a
speech with the prime minister the next
week and in the conversations about
putting that speech together on the
economy it was clear our differences
were too big to reconcile okay so that
was the reason plus i think let's not
look at the hit the bass with
rose-tinted spectacles here everyone
remembers what was going on with chris
pincher right
that was a serious ethical question that
the government was on the wrong side of
again and i couldn't defend it maybe
you're okay to defend that i wasn't okay
to defend it 60 other members of the
government were not okay to defend it
because it was wrong and that's why
we're here because we need to change
things we need to bring trust and
integrity and decency and honesty back
into politics and that's what i want to
do as prime minister okay okay i'm going
to have to brush up on my shakespearean
references i can tell
um let's bring in david from london
finally where are you david david's here
hi davey gone hi kay thank you david hi
good evening mr cena
how were you balance the need to address
the escalating cost of living crisis
particularly for those that are on lower
incomes
alongside the need to keep the economy
in good order and national debt not
spiraling out of control
david you know your question
is actually the most important one
facing the country right now right and
i'm sure many of you saw what the bank
and the bank of england had to say today
and if we in the conservative party need
to get real and fast because the lights
on the economy are flashing red and the
root cause is inflation now i'm worried
that liz truss's plans will make the
situation worse and what i want to do is
different i think the government's
number one priority should be grappling
with inflation that's what i want to do
i also want to help people with the cost
of living over the autumn and winter
particularly as you said the people who
most need our help and that's what i
announced as chancellor that's how i
acted over the past two years that's
what i'll do as your prime minister
that's what a conservative government
should do support those who need our
help most at a time of need but then
also
i want to grow the economy and i want
businesses to be producing more and
that's how we're going to not just grow
the economy and create jobs is how we're
going to get inflation down over time
i've got a plan to do all of those
things but it all starts with not making
the situation worse because if we just
put fuel on the fire of this inflation
spiral all of us all of you are going to
just end up with higher mortgage rates
savings and pensions that are eaten away
and misery for millions i don't want
that to happen and that's why i am so
focused on gripping inflation first okay
ladies and gentlemen mr sunak have a
seat all right
need any water yes why not right
excellent
right my turn here we go let's uh talk
about the economy to start with should
we today as was being pointed at the
bank of england uh saying that we're
going to be in recession before the end
of the year and that's going to last
until 2024.
people watching at home and i'm guessing
some people here as well facing months
and months of hardship you've been their
chancellor for the last two years why on
earth should they trust you with the
keys of number 10
in fact because they've seen me as
chancellor over the last couple of years
and i think actually okay probably the
first time people really saw me was that
first press conference
when there was an enormous amount of
anxiety in the country about what was
going to happen to people's jobs their
livelihoods their businesses
and they didn't really know who i was
i'd just been a maid chancellor a couple
of weeks before but i stepped up at that
moment to act boldly and radically to
design things that had never been done
before in this country like furlough
that ended up protecting over 10 million
jobs saved over a million businesses
help families get through what are two
very difficult years and for our economy
to
emerge at the end of that in far more
resilient shape than anyone had
anticipated at the beginning and when i
go around the country people know that
that's what i did for them they're
grateful for it and that's what i want
to do as prime minister because right
now we face similarly large economic
challenges and it's particularly because
of their experience that i'm well placed
to deal with nothing you can do about
recession there is there or is there
of course there is of course back to
david david's question
that the number one thing we have to do
is not make the situation worse what is
causing the recession right as you heard
from the bank of england today and i
think liz said something before which
i'm just gonna correct it's not the tax
burden that is causing the recession
that's simply wrong what's causing the
recession is inflation right that's the
root of the problems we have not just
here but in america and elsewhere so the
way we're going to get through this
first and foremost is gripping inflation
now we will and i always have stood by
people as you've seen me over the last
couple of years so i will help people
get through the autumn in the winter as
i've done before and then we will make
the right reforms to help grow the
economy in the long term and i i don't
think the corporate tax proposals more
money to help people of course i would
do you know how much we'll have to see
the size of the problem but look people
can see 13.3 percent inflation is what's
predicted that yeah that's the size of
the problem and i don't want that to be
worse
and i don't want it to last longer so
what i'm not going to do is embark on a
borrowing spree worth tens of billions
of pounds put that on the country's
credit card ask our kids and our
grandkids to pick up the tab because
that's not right it's not responsible
and it's certainly not conservative but
you're promising tax cuts without
knowing where inflation will be
i'm the one that's not standing here
sitting here now uh promising tens of
billions of pounds of unfunded tax cuts
what you've actually said is no tax cuts
until inflation gets under control what
amounts to under control
when it's on a clearly downward
trajectory and where we have good line
of sight that is returning back to
target right okay right but that doesn't
but that's why we need to be really
careful about policies that will make
that worse right and look i you know if
if that took the first question uh you
know i'm behind in this race i'm just a
bit confused so are you saying these
income tax cuts might not happen
you're talking about my longer term yes
of course i am yeah my my longer term
plan i'm confident we can deliver it yes
right and that was the reason i
published that longer term plan and that
longer term plan for those watching was
to over time reduce income tax rates in
this country because i believe
really strongly in rewarding hard work
hard work is a value that i think is
really important i think most
conservatives share that view that hard
work is something that should be
rewarded the the best way to do that
through the tax system is to reduce the
rate of income tax and i wanted to give
people a sense of the direction of where
i wanted to take the country and the
economy and i want to build an economy
where we cut the rates of income tax
over time and we're going to do that not
by asking our kids to pick up the bill
we're going to do it by being
disciplined on public spending
you're very comfortable we know exactly
what you think what we don't probably
know about is foreign affairs as much um
so let me ask you about energy and food
bills and how that relates to foreign
affairs potentially
how high
do you think that energy and food bills
will have to go before we
reassess our support for ukraine
no i don't i don't think that's how
we're going to look at it actually
because we can make an enormous
difference
over between now and actually next
winter in reducing our dependence on
russian energy so in the short term of
course we're going to step in and i want
to step in and help people more i
announced enormous support as chancellor
as prime minister i'll go further
because the situation is deteriorated
but what i'm looking to is by next
winter that we've got through this and
there's lots of things we can do to help
us do that so i give a couple of
examples right so one thing we can do is
improve our energy storage because
actually we can import lots of gas in
the middle of the year takes time no no
we actually we can do that relatively
quickly improved energy storage during
the middle of the year but the other
thing we can do is energy efficiency now
many of you here many people watching
are living in homes where we can help
improve the insulation loft insulation
cavity wall insulation smart temperature
controls those are relatively small
scale interventions that don't take very
long or cost a fortune and government
has got money but if we turbo charge
that program we can not only reduce our
demand for energy which improves our
energy security we can also save people
up to 300 pounds on their bills now
that's the type of thing that we should
continue to support ukraine as long as
we like
our loft is that what you're saying we
need to be lagging our loft anyway for
climate change reasons right because
it's good to reduce our long-term demand
on energy right but what we do want to
do is make sure we help people with
their bills and that's a good practical
example of something we can do on the
conflict in ukraine boris johnson has um
really thrown himself into the cause i
think everybody might agree with that
he's regarded as a hero apparently in
ukraine that's what he tells us he
brandishes his missile launchers we've
seen that are you really
tough enough to stand up
to vladimir putin well just think for a
moment how are we currently standing
this is your hell yeah moment yeah so
how are we standing up to vladimir putin
right how are we actually doing it we're
doing two things right we're sending
arms
and money to ukraine which as we talked
about earlier i found from elsewhere in
government spending so that we could
free up that money to send to president
zielenski but what's the other way we're
weakening russia we're doing it through
economic sanctions right we're not
sending our troops into russia right
it's not diplomatic measures that are
making a difference it's economic what
are we doing we're targeting his
companies their access to global capital
markets his gold trading his central
bank reserves that's how we're
economically turning the screw on russia
who do you think put all those things
together
i did with all my finance minister
colleagues around the world working with
a treasury secretary in america working
with european finance ministers we
designed an international package of
economic sanctions that would send a
very strong message that we will not
stand for his aggression it's the most
stringent set of economic sanctions the
world has ever seen and it is making a
difference and as prime minister i will
go further because there's more things
we can do so
yes i'm tough enough and i'm already
delivering the measures that are
actually causing him the most trouble
thank you
ben wallace
as we i mentioned before said that you
had to be overruled on defense spending
pretty patel the home secretary
reportedly said that you objected to the
rwanda plan during a written discussion
between the departments brandon lewis
the northern ireland secretary former
northern ireland secretary has accused
you of putting up huge resistance on our
efforts to override the northern ireland
protocol it looks as though there's a
recurring theme there doesn't that you
say one thing in private and then you
say something else for
voter consumption so should we believe
them
or should we believe you look when it
comes to the rwanda plan
i do believe in the rwanda policy but do
i ask tough questions when cabinet
ministers come to me and say oh look
we'd like to do this new thing yeah
because my job is to make sure that
yours and everyone else watching and
everyone in this audience's money is
spent properly that's part of my job i
wouldn't be doing my job properly if
every time some cabinet minister came to
me and said oh please can i have x
billion pounds to do this new thing i
don't say well hang on let me just check
that this actually is going to work is
it worth our spending taxpayers money
spending 120 million pounds um on
sending 200 people to rwanda is good
value for money yeah well it's the pilot
right so the pilot bit is expensive so
you're asking now exactly the questions
i was asking so if pretty patel or
anyone else is going to say oh now i
expressed some doubts about it it was
doubts about how we're going to make the
policy work i believe in the policy but
it's not good enough in government to
just announce things that's not good
enough to put out a press release it's
what you need to do is deliver things
and i think what people saw from me
during the pandemic as chancellor that i
could deliver things i actually
delivered policies that worked and made
a difference which by the way were done
in record time and were radical and i
will bring that same sense of grip and
urgency and competence to all these
other challenges whether it's the rwanda
policy whether it's the nhs backlogs
okay let's talk about climate you
brought it up we're trying to whizz
through these topics as best we can
because obviously some of these people
have not got their ballot papers yet
some have and what you're telling them
both here in the studio and at home this
evening could make the difference as to
whether or not you are the next prime
minister of this country so let's talk
about the climate should we one issue
that affects not just our finances but
of course our future
is um your green credentials can i test
them
sure here we go
new coal mines
yes or no
they're local decisions but i don't
think we should be
importing coal from other places if we
have it at home okay what about fracking
where where has the support of local
communities i'm in favor of it okay but
we have seen some big issues with
fracking haven't we particularly in my
part of the world in the northwest of
england uh where we've seen at least
three earthquakes that apparently uh
have been caused by fracking yeah but we
also as i said most importantly it has
to be done with the support of local
communities but we do also have a study
from i think
i think three different royal societies
i think of geologists and engineers and
and i can't remember the third group but
it's online somewhere all of whom said
that they believe fracking is safe and
the seismic activity is not out of the
ordinary they're all the scientists who
have came to that conclusion not me but
as i said i'm supportive of it where we
can bring the local community along with
us because if we can get it to work it's
good for our long-term energy would you
raise flight taxes would i raise flight
taxes no why not well well i for because
as chancellor i already made a change to
airline taxation i'm very green though
uh yes it was actually because i did two
things one is i i reversed a european
rule that forced us to charge people
twice when they flew inside of the
united kingdom on air air passing duty i
didn't think that was right and after we
left the eu we could say we're not going
to do that anymore if you fly around the
uk because we believe in the united
kingdom we should only be taxed once but
at the same time i created a new band
for the
longest tall flights the most polluting
flights we created a brand new band with
a higher level of tax so actually it was
balanced right so for the people who are
flying the farthest with the more
emissions they were going to pay more
for people flying within the united
kingdom we took an advantage of brexit
let me ask you about onshore wind yes or
no because i'm a bit confused on this
i'm not offshoring i'm sure when forgive
me yes or no no okay you've changed your
mind no i haven't i just last night i
was asked a question i didn't fully
understand it and i misspoke but my
position on that is the same as it's
been okay how are we going to get to net
zero by 2050
with innovation yeah and the type of
future economy that i want to create is
one where this and we talked about it in
the answer to the the visas question
from someone uh if if we have an economy
where this is the best place in the
world for people to create invent
discover new things we will get there
and we will get there in a way that
lowers people's bills now look my
business background my experience means
i know how to build that type of economy
and this we've got to rush through this
okay well that's important
yeah quick fire there's an enormous
opportunity
if you don't mind quick fire questions
here we go do you personally support the
24-week limit on abortion uh as a
personal thing yes
i mean these these are these are
personal decisions they're not
government decisions
i don't think there's any need to change
the i believe in a woman's right to
choose i don't think there's any reason
to change the laws that we have why have
you abstained on every major vote on
abortion uh probably because i've not
been in parliament on the day
you didn't think it was important enough
to be there because as chancellor i'm
often traveling
2015 apparently were you chancellor in
2015 uh no but i mean i these are these
are not free i mean i completely agree
with our current system of abortion i
don't think it should be changed so if
the v i mean so that's my general view
that's always been you just haven't you
just haven't been there when the votes
have been taking place would you fist
bump uh the saudi leader mohammed bin
salman as joe biden did
i'm probably not a fist bumping type of
person i think probably
just shake his hand then i mean
yes i will shake his hand i generally i
think you do have to engage with people
around the world i i don't think and
they're a country that we have a
relationship with
uh in a video here it comes from 2001
you said you didn't have any
working-class friends have you made any
working-class friends since you left
university yeah i mean i i was i think i
was a student when i said that we all
say silly things when when we're younger
i mean at the same time i was as you
know i was working at my mom's shop i
was out and about cycling around running
around delivering medicines to people or
people from all walks of life but you
know obviously i was a kid and i said
something silly so you do have
working-class friends now yeah i mean i
don't go around asking them what they're
they're they're how they define
themselves
i mean i i i think we've kind of moved i
think we've moved beyond that as a
country actually yeah i reassure you
yeah i think people are less interested
in where you've come from people are
interested in where you're going that's
the kind of country i want to build
right
thank you yeah
let me ask you the same question that is
trust about being prime minister being
the most invasive exposed period in any
politician's life anything you want to
tell us about
no i mean look i've had i've had a
relatively high profile job for two
years and i think people have seen me in
action and they've seen hey what i can
do they've seen much of my personal life
has also been talked about earlier this
year and that was an experience that i
took uh you know that i learned from and
and dealt with so yes i'm used to the
scrutiny another simple question have
you ever
benefited financially from the use of
tax havens no
a venture capital firm you co-founded
tailman partners was registered in the
cayman islands
um so just to clarify i i personally
and have paid absolutely full normal
taxes wherever i've lived did you set up
that business no okay so you know you
weren't a co-founder in 2000 and not the
bit in the cayman islands you're
referring to i have nothing to do with
okay i mean i happen to work with a
company that has multiple offices all
around the all around the world but
that's not my responsibility it was not
running the company
anyway paid by that offshore company no
connections with it when i was living in
america i paid all my taxes in america
and when i've lived in the uk i've paid
all my taxes in the uk as completely as
anyone else okay the reason i'm asking
is that as you know as all our audience
know you've had to clarify your wife's
non-dom status you held permanent
residency in the united states while he
was setting the taxes of british voters
which is what a green card means
you're building a swimming pool at your
constituency home while the public pool
in richmond is facing closure after a
400 energy hike
this is all led to a perception problem
for you people feel that you can't walk
a mile in their shoes because you're
walking in your prada shoes what would
you say to them
you know so
you know over the past couple of weeks
right i've been out and about across the
country talking talking members talking
to members of the public and
as i was saying lots of people have
come to talk to me about that press
conference and furlough and what
difference it made to their lives do you
know i
i was wearing the same suit in that
press conference the same shoes as that
i'm wearing now right i'm the same
person how much were they worth yeah i'm
very slick i'm exactly the same person
right i'm the same person that stood
there and made sure that we helped the
country through a very difficult time
and that's what i'll do as prime
minister and i think the british people
judge people by their character and by
their actions not by their bank account
that certainly seems to be the case as
far as the audience is concerned here
but there's plenty of people who are
watching at home who would disagree with
that perception is reality and they
think that you're too rich to be prime
minister yeah well the reality is one of
the last things i did as chancellor was
announce significant help for people
with their energy bills this ultimate
winter and to the question we had at the
front
from david i think it was right
that was david's question was about
helping the most vulnerable right people
who really needed help that's what i did
because look we're all going to have a
difficult time and and inflation makes
everyone poorer and that's why i'm so
concerned about policies that will make
it worse and last longer and that's not
right but when we do need to help people
this autumn winter our focus should be
on the people who most need our help and
actually you know when liz is sitting
here saying she's going to scrap the nhs
levy do you know who that benefits that
benefits the top 15
of earners right that's what that policy
does it's not going to help the people
that david was asking about with the
cost of living this winter right the
policies i announced as chancellor are
targeted on those people because they
are the people that need our help right
it's going to be really tough
it's going to be really tough for lots
of people and much as i want to support
them to work hard and do those things
right it's going to be just impossible
for some people and we need to help them
and that's what i did you can't do all
of that on your own um penny mordent has
backed ms trust ben wallace says back
mistrust nadim zahawi has backed
mistrust tom tougenhart has backed uh
liz trust sagi javid your old boss has
backed ms truss why are so many people
supporting her rather than you right but
but kay goes back to the question right
at the beginning
every stage of the parliamentary process
i had the broadest and biggest number of
support most closely with you and
they've decided that they prefer her
hang on the most mps in parliament and
all mps work together in lots of
different guys people walk around the
cabinet table with you day in and day
out and they said you know what actually
top two gonna happen
are not in the cabinet okay um but
every single
round of the parliamentary press would
have been your capital i led
right i was the person that mps chose
every round ahead of everyone else and
since it finished more and more people
have come and joined the team so i'm
actually i'm really humbled by that and
i'm delighted and actually as we're
answering a question that support is
drawn really widely from across the
parliamentary party and and i'm not
going to get into who's going to have
this job in that job i've got a contest
that i want to try and win i want to be
out and about talking to all of you
about my ideas for the future but i will
build a team that reflects all the
talent and traditions of our party as i
said you saw a lot of that on display in
this leadership contest and as we talked
about before we're all one team we're
all one family we're going to come
together after this we're going to serve
the british people and then we're going
to take it to kirsten and win the next
election because that's the real prize
final thought when you go you know when
you look at yourself in the mirror at
night just before you go to bed and you
think all these people that have sat
around the cabinet table with me and now
they don't want to work with me they
think that the other candidates better
plenty of people sat around the cabinet
table also support me
right dominic robb the deputy prime
minister is out there right now talking
about it and lots of others but i also
as i said now
actually just him right
i think we only just have one person
right yeah much as we love you and we
love sky i think we tolerate just one
person giving up their evening to come
and talk to you later but
you know i've been you know i've been
really hard to take that actually
i think i think the perfect place to end
it
thank you very
much very nice to see you thank you very
much
one second
so
so our candidates have had their chance
to make their case but what do the
people who will decide their future make
of it we have a simple question for our
audience are you ready audience we
rehearsed this beforehand after what you
have heard tonight
who are you most likely to vote for as
you know you need to press one and then
send if it's rishi sunak and you need to
press two and then send if it is
liz trust are we all ready
any more questions before we need to do
that everybody knows exactly what
they're going to say and do
away you go there we go so we have 15
seconds when people were pressing one
for rishi sunak or two full is trus and
then pressing pressing send
and then
as if by magic in just a few moments
time we'll find out what our audience
here in the studio thinks about who
should be the next prime minister of
this country worth just pointing out at
this stage that naught point three
percent of the electorate will decide
our next prime minister which means 99.7
percent of the electorate will not be
doing that do you think that's fair
yes yes yes why do you think it's fair
gentlemen here why do you think it's
fair my ballot paper doesn't say who's
the next prime minister we have a
parliamentary system people voted for
the conservative party and as members
we're electing the leader it happens to
be that that leader becomes prime
minister
this is a basic understanding of
ourselves quickly thank you gentlemen up
here really quickly with a check shirt
yeah it's exactly the same as what
labour do okay when they chose um okay
now as with all things with live
television the technology has crashed
so what we're going to do instead is go
with a a show of hands instead are we
happy with that
so will you will you allow me to say who
i think has probably got more hands
thank you so if you think that rishi
sunak had a better show and as a result
would potentially make the better prime
minister of this country can you put
your hand up now ladies and gentlemen
please oh my goodness that looks to me
like an awful lot for mr sunak who would
prefer miss truss as the next prime
minister now
i i wasn't expecting that i have to say
but i think with just keeping your hands
up for mistrust while we just get some
more shots just to show people at home
it looks to me as though mr tsunak
convinced you far more than um miss
tross um and i'm sorry sir we're almost
out of time and i have had you let let
you have a couple of goals i think the
only thing that you probably needs to
learn from tonight is to read a bit
shakespeare i don't know what you think
anyway it's been fantastic to see you
all thank you so much for taking the
time for joining us thank you also to
miss trust and also uh to mr tsunak they
were amazing thank you very much indeed
for joining us
really really appreciate it
very very enlightening conversation and
discussion from both of them coming up
in just a few moments time jane secker
will be talking to both uh mr quarten
and also mr raab and i will see you very
soon good evening thank you for joining
us
thank you very much okay well there you
have it the battle for number 10.
there's trust and rishi soon answering
questions from our studio audience made
up of conservative party members lots
and lots to chew through lots of really
interesting points let's get some
instant reaction to what we've just seen
and heard our deputy political editor
sam coates is with me here sam what for
you is the biggest headline of the night
well wasn't that fascinating because
what i think we had tonight was the most
challenging the most
in-depth grilling that those two
candidates have had so far on the
campaign trail and what set it apart was
this wasn't
just narrowly a contest this wasn't a a
debate or a set of interests just
answering the concerns of tory members
this covered the whole
the whole gamut of issues of concern uh
to the nation uh for whoever uh wins
this contest becomes prime minister in a
month and two days and what was
fascinating is you saw really the two
candidates weak spots exposed pretty
ruthlessly uh i thought by um kate
burley and and they were different
things so with liz trust what you heard
time and again was an attempt to push
back at the way that she would make
promises or she would defend what a
point sounded like
some pretty hard positions that she got
into so uh one of the most eye-catching
moments of that debate of that encounter
was when she was asked what she'd do to
help people in the cost of living crisis
and she said i will do all i can now
that's not a commitment that we've heard
before she caveated it by saying well uh
based on uh what i can afford but that
kind of broad brush promise looks until
now to have gone down incredibly well
with the party uh and that's what's
catapulted apparently into the lead
but at the same time
she was clearly happy to make promises
unclear quite where some of the money uh
was coming from billions potentially uh
to try and look again at doctor's
pensions and she found herself being
challenged by the audience on soundline
let's hear uh some of what uh liz trust
ended up saying to kay burley well what
the bank of england have said today is
of course extremely worrying but it is
not inevitable we can change the outcome
and we can make it more likely that the
economy grows but what i can assure you
k
is i will do all i can to help people
who are struggling with the cost of
living i understand that people are
going through difficult times and if
there are any more available resources
of course i would put that to helping
people with the cost of living you said
that public sector pay policy has been
misrepresented by the media here's the
proposals that you released introduce
regional pay boards tailoring pay to the
cost of living where civil servants
actually work saving up to 8.8 billion
pounds per year so how have we
misrepresented you so far well what what
i am clear about
is that policy was not about teachers
and doctors but can i be clear kay
that i'm not going ahead with this you
can but you said you were because i'm
just clarifying because because of the
concerns that have been expressed okay
and when something is just clarified
when there's an issue okay i deal with
it okay but just to clarify whether you
were misrepresented or not you
highlighted a very specific saving 8.8
billion pounds how did you reach that
figure
well i don't have the details i can tell
you okay there are no skeletons in my
closet i think everything i've ever said
and done is known about very publicly
what was so interesting about the way
that uh liz truss responded under the
spotlight is we're challenged she would
dig in and dig in not necessarily
offering any more information uh but
when challenged she refused to apologize
on that public sector paid gap where you
just saw her being challenged over
claiming that the media misrepresented
but then being unable to explain that
challenged overwatch to the u-turn on
british fighters to ukraine uh she just
said uh she never admitted uh really to
making uh a mistake uh on restoring
trust as you just heard her say there
are no skeletons in her closet there was
a rider that aren't already known will
that come back to haunter we don't know
we asked both candidates that it's the
eternal question for politicians but
interestingly she refused to commit to a
new ethics adviser uh necessarily
appointed a new ethics advisor i think
what we got from liz trust is somebody
who like boris johnson can be stubborn
like boris johnson doesn't back down
what we got from rishi sunak was
something very different what he faced a
challenge on was his record personal and
political let's hear a bit of how he was
forced to defend the help out to eat out
scheme
you were also the chancellor that
introduced eat out to dine out
at a cost of 850 million pounds and
according to the university of warwick
that was responsible for an increase of
nuclear cases of between 8 and 17
well actually that's one study that said
that and i don't think it's right
we need to change the definition of
asylum and move away from this european
definition which has become very broad
it's exploited by lefty lawyers and
means it's very hard to remove people
fundamentally we must get a grip of this
we have to make the rwanda policy work i
will do whatever it takes including
legal changes if required to make it
work
you've been campaigning for a long time
and it was perfectly timed a cynical
motivation to try and get you into
number 10. no that's just
simply not true so i was due to give a
speech with the prime minister the next
week and in the conversations about
putting that speech together on the
economy it was clear our differences
were too big to reconcile okay so that
was the reason plus i think let's not
look at the hit the bass with
rose-tinted spectacles here everyone
remembers what was going on with chris
pincher right
that was a serious ethical question that
the government was on the wrong side of
again
i'm the same person that stood there and
made sure that we helped the country
through a very difficult time and that's
what i'll do as prime minister and i
think the british people judge people by
their character and by their actions not
by their bank account
and what's really amazing jane about all
of those bits of the rishi sunak
grilling is that here we have somebody
who is a relatively short-lived
chancellor as they go
repeatedly being forced to defend his
record whether it was diddy knife boris
johnson well in the job uh or whether or
not he his stewardship of the economy is
now responsible for such high inflation
now if you look at his rival liz trust
is the longest serving cabinet minister
yet it's rishi sunak for whom his record
is the issue that audience members and
questions by kay burleigh repeatedly
came back to rishi sunak's inheritance i
think was the thing that came under the
spotlight the most today i think it was
liz trust's plans for the future her
stubbornness that was really highlighted
in the last 90 minutes
okay sam thanks very much for that snap
instant analysis uh well we've also got
the two representatives of the two
candidates who we spoke to earlier
they've stayed behind to react to it for
us we have dominic robb the deputy prime
minister and justice secretary and for
his trust we have the business secretary
quasi quarten and uh dominic rob can i
come to you first just just because we
just had that audience vote there at the
end uh the national uh polls amongst
conservative leaders put liz trust well
ahead but but clearly in that audience
vote at the end there he he did enough
to win people over were you surprised
that so many people in the audience
appeared to to be won over by rishi
sunak
no i wasn't uh
and i think first of all in terms of the
arguments by the way i thought it was a
good debate and both candidates uh quit
themselves well and i thought the format
was uh useful for teasing out the real
issues but i just felt rishi was more
credible on the economy more compelling
when it comes to the issue of uniting
the party and actually in that bit at
the end where they all both candidates
face tricky questions he responded very
strongly and as we saw i think he got
the two candidates the most applause and
i think by something like 75 percent one
uh won the the the show of hands in the
audience and the truth is the more
people see rishi sanak uh the more
compelling and the more they warm
towards him and the more that this
contest will go our way
uh quality cost i mean we don't know how
these voters felt beforehand we know
that the majority of them said to us
that they were undecided um but but do
you think that that that liz trust
perhaps didn't quite hit the mark
tonight
look i think she did a good job but i
think russia was very fluent
uh but where and he was slick more
fluent
but where i where i disagree with him
was on the fundamentals of what he said
i don't believe that you grow an economy
by raising taxes he made the point that
the recession was caused by the
inflation
but why would you increase taxes if
people are suffering from uh the cost of
living he also said something which ben
wallace
directly questioned a week ago in
relation to the defense settlement uh
rishi claimed that was entirely his uh
doing but ben suggested that the prime
minister might have had a hand
in that so there were a number of things
and of course there was the question
about his loyalty and his support for
the prime minister i think rishi did a
good job in answering that but these are
the kinds of doubts that many people
many of our members
have and it was very good that they were
aired i think rishi did well he answered
many of those challenges uh effectively
but these are the kinds of questions
that are going to keep cropping up and
it's very fair that they should do so
liz trust um quasi quasang
she did dig in uh sam coates was
pointing out to lots of the questions
she was asked by the audience and by kay
not willing to apologize not willing to
to
to
really grow back on on many things that
she had said do you think that is the
right strategy is that there's those who
will say it's good to be confident in
your beliefs but you also don't want to
come across as being too strident
well she's she's not strident at all
actually the thing that she was
questioned about most by kay
was uh the original pay and she said
that that was something uh that she felt
uh she had to act quickly and decisively
she's a very sincere politician she's
straightforward according to her own
words she's not as slick as many other
presenters but she's sincere she's
honest she's hard working and i think
she'll be a fabulous prime minister
dominic rob why do you think russia
sunix record
is something that that people seem so
keen to scrutinize as sam coates was
saying you know he he has been a
chancellor for a relatively short period
of time
yet and a lot has happened during that
period of time it has to be said yet
there is a great deal of focus and a
great deal of scrutiny on on what he has
done
i think being chancellor the exchequer
is a second biggest job in government uh
and uh after being prime minister and to
to be honest with you i thought the most
comfortable moments for rishi was when
he got the chance to answer why he took
the measures he did
to help people through the pandemic the
12 million jobs that were were saved as
a result of that
unprecedented intervention in response
to unprecedented times uh how he's got
the economy going and what his plans are
for the future um so i think i think in
politics you expect a combination of
being have your records scrutinized but
also your plans for the future and i
thought uh he dealt with that grilling
particularly well um and that shows i
think he's thought things through he
didn't get hung up in the same way as
liz did on a reversal of a paper uh
regional pay policy that just been
announced because he thinks things
through and i think that's an important
characteristic in a prime minister
particularly at this time when there is
so many risks around with inflation with
interest rates
and i think that just re reinforced his
credibility
well we thank you both so much for
coming along this evening and staying
along after the
discussion you started with him and then
ended with him so i'm very very go on
had the last word very briefly quasi
no i just want to say very quickly that
liz is not the slickest presenter she
said that but she's sincere hard-working
and trustworthy and that's what we've
got to remember we've got to have
someone that we can trust and that can
be trusted to deliver and liz is that
person
let it not be said that we are not
even-handed quasi quartong and dominic
thank you both very much indeed
well let's just see how tori supporters
out in the country feel about what they
have heard this evening got a sense from
the audience what they thought but let's
go to mari aurora she is up there in
worcester and has been gauging reaction
there murray which candidate seemed to
win over the voters where you are and
what do they think about how both
performed
well it's still a very mixed bag i would
say the liz trust supporters seem to be
have kind of solidified their support
for liz trust rishi sunac supporters
similar and some undecided supporters
now veering towards rashiduna but let me
take you over so we can speak to them so
to start with this is adele she's a
liz trust supporter so why are you
sticking with liz after watching that
debate well i think they both perform
really well richie's obviously a very
slick performer um he's he speaks very
strongly on the economy um and he said
the economy is the most important thing
i'm not sure i agree with him i think
there are other things are just as
important
um you know the issues that we've got in
our health care and when he i mean his
argument with that one because he's less
strong on on that area was to issue this
fine for people who don't attend
appointments and i think that that will
affect the poorest and most vulnerable
in society unfairly where liz said that
the money they got ring fenced full um
social care that she would direct
um through to um the social care because
there's a big backlog there and i
thought that was a more convincing
argument for me that was just one of the
things you know the substance of what
they have to say so yeah i'll still be
with liz trust i think yeah okay so
adele there not convinced by rishi sunax
promises around the nhs now if we speak
to christine and george over here they
both were undecided and are now
convinced by rishi soon actually
christine tell me why was she still like
when you over
i think rishi sunet came over as very
strong
very principled
and very honest and i think that's what
the public need is a politician who they
can trust
i think you can trust him with the
economy he's had a great experience
uh with the economy he's been very good
chancellor he's looked after people
during the pandemic which
seems to be glossed over the cost of the
pandemic
by the general public
and i think he would make a fine prime
minister i think he's he's not phased by
difficult questions
um
liz trust i thought did very well
but um to me
she's a good trade minister um
i just can't see her as being a strong
enough prime minister i don't think
she's
got the experience
and the drive i think
i think sorry no we can we can see
christine not convinced by liz trust
there and just want to squeeze in one
per one more voter before we leave so
mark over here still not convinced by
either why are you still on the fence
mark well i think both of them are
excellent actually i think they're both
pointable and i think they both beat kia
stammer and i was particularly pleased
to hear liz trust tonight because i was
just a bit worried that whether she was
strong enough to do that and she
convinced me that if she gets it she
will do a great job i knew rishi was a
great performer and i think both of them
either of them now will will do uh will
keep the conservative flag flying high
okay so as you can see here in worcester
still very much all to play for but what
i would say is we've had so many people
on the fence here i'm just going to ask
very quickly this room put your hands up
if you're now voting for rishi sunak
put your hands up if you're voting for
liz truss
and put your hands up if you still don't
know
okay as you can see almost an even split
so we still don't know in worcester uh
back to you in the studio
what more can we do murray how many more
questions can we ask for them uh mario
or there thanks so much in worcester
well let's get some snap analysis from
our three special correspondents helen
ann smith on business and the economy
ashes joshie on the nhs social care and
thomas moore on climate change and and
before the debate we asked you what you
thought was going to feature what you
thought was going to be important helen
ann
given what we've heard from the bank of
england
the cost of living was was a big thing
that you thought would feature but but
what do you think you heard any
solutions well really interestingly i
think there was a big opportunity for
the candidates to really show that they
grasped the gravity of the moment and
really understood the severity of the
crisis that people are going to face
this winter and there was a lot of big
arguments weren't there about tax and
growth and a lot of these arguments we
have heard before they're quite well
trodden but there was almost nothing
about very specific targeted
packages of measures that frankly are
going to be needed this winter based on
what the bank of england said today a
long recession spiraling inflation
energy bills three times what they were
last winter and i think it's debatable
whether either of them really sort of on
show that they truly understood just how
very serious it's going to be for some
families this winter very well trodden
arguments about tax and growth and
we can argue about those but but i'm
surprised that there wasn't anything a
bit more specific a bit more agile okay
ashish what about the nhs uh rishi
tsunak of course again talks about his
heritage within the nhs is dad being a
doctor his mum being a pharmacist uh he
talked about missed appointments but did
you think there could have been more
about about the nhs it could definitely
have been more about the nhs i think
this was a missed opportunity for both
candidates i think nhs trust leaders
will look at this debate this evening
and say nothing was said to address the
problems that exist already and the
problems which are coming to the nhs
further down the line nothing pledged no
more new money nothing to address the
workforce issues
liz trust talked about the efficiencies
within the system so did rishi sunak
they talked about the existing money
that's already earmarked with the health
and social care levy and
most people have looked at rishi sanak's
idea about uh 10 pound fines for missed
gp appointments that will not solve the
nhs crisis so it was an opportunity for
both of them to really address what is
happening in the nhs and social care
sector i think both failed uh finally
let's talk climate change with thomas
more and beforehand we said we weren't
sure whether it would be a really big
concern for many members of the audience
liz trust didn't really
get challenged about it at all did she
she didn't no but she did in the context
of both energy security and indeed
energy bills talk about oil and gas from
the north sea twice and i think that
will concern many environmentalists that
her go-to on both occasions is fossil
fuels not solar and wind which is where
the country has been going up to this
point now
rishi sunak was grilled more on this and
many environmentalists will be
encouraged that he did talk about home
energy and efficiency home insulation
and so on uh that he did give a
commitment to net zero in terms of uh
innovation but they will be concerned
that he still talks about uh coal mining
here in the uk as a source of energy
that again is the dirtiest fuel uh dirt
as source of of uh carbon dioxide and
fossil fuels and that will cause some
concern
okay well thank you all three of you uh
really interesting to to get your
thoughts of things you were specifically
listening out for this evening
well let's see what some of our studio
audience made of it they sat through it
all they got up close and personal uh
with the politicians they got a chance
to ask some pretty uh
specific questions to them our political
correspondent tomorrow cohen uh has
caught up with a few of them now
tomorrow
hi jane yes i'm here with some of our
audience who were listening in as they
try to make their decisions rishi sunak
or liz trust and i'm going to introduce
you to a few of them and hear what
they've got to say and first of all i've
got zayd from birmingham zayd were you
late leaning in any particular direction
and did tonight change things for you no
no i was undecided i was undecided but
tonight i think performance wise rishi
i'd go rishi but still i think we still
got a couple of weeks left um liz could
again perform even better so
you'll be waiting it out to make your
choice definitely and what on what
particular issues was rishi the best i
mean he obviously feels very comfortable
on the economy was that was that it for
you i think i think he knows the detail
um of course he was chancellor for two
years but i think he knows the detail
more um and the questions that was
coming his way and economy i think he
was responding really well and really
quickly as well and where do you think
liz truss fell down for you if she did
at all uh not really i don't think she
fell down in any matter but i think in
terms of details as i said i think rishi
mastered it a lot more i think but maybe
because he was chancellor so uh
and liz wasn't and mary um you are
mary's a care manager from london and
you were very impressed with what liz
trust was saying on social care yep i
thought that she said something
different from what she said before she
wants a lot more money going into social
care
that's why i voted for her tonight
because that's my field and i know what
people are facing out there yeah there's
been a lot of criticism of her not
wanting to raise national insurance to
pay for the nhs but you thought that she
made it clear what she was actually
going to do tonight did you think were
you thinking before tonight that you
weren't sure what her plans were yeah i
wasn't sure but
she made it clear today the way she's
going to tackle the social care crisis
and i was so impressed that was so i
voted for her tonight and so she she
gets it you think she gets it but what
do do you fear that with these tax cuts
that she might not have the money left i
mean inflation is is rising isn't it
well i no doubt but i know she would
deliver she will keep to her promise
yeah so you feel you feel that she's
she's she's the one for you and and
rishi isn't
doesn't have that strong world strong
emphasis on social media
i mean he didn't mention it tonight
so
that's why and my aim here it was that
particular thing and uh lottie what did
you what did you make of it um who who
was the winner for you well i think just
based on their performance tonight um
rishi
put on a better show
um i think he gives very straightforward
answers which i think is quite important
uh considering the past couple of years
of politics
i think he can restore integrity and
trust because that's so important isn't
it in this context well i think either
winner needs to do that uh there's not
really a question about that um but i
just think that uh rishi seems like he
has a bit of a party within westminster
behind him and i'm hoping that in 2024
he potentially will gain their lecture
he gets stick disney from some members
saying you you knifed boris johnson we
didn't want to get rid of boris johnson
and you led that is that an issue for
you and for you claire as well did was
that is that an issue for you with rishi
su-neck um not particularly uh we've
seen that done in the past before boris
did it uh himself i think so
uh it's i i'm more focused on on the
policies uh i think tonight he was quite
confused he was he was quite clear
uh about looking at what was happening
at the time with the pincher case uh and
he just couldn't take anymore so i think
he was right
clarifying that important you feel he
would he would restore standards
um and and what about on the sort of
policy issues did you feel that liz
trust fell down on anything or there was
anything you didn't know about her that
you found out tonight
uh i thought trust has some very fresh
ideas in terms of especially the
investment zones and things that young
people really care about in terms of
uh fixing the planning uh system and uh
and trying to create
uh more home owners uh and more
people with uh
who
kind of can afford a house and lottie
you were telling us that um that you
there was one one issue on which you
didn't know what richie sunic thought
what was that
well i do think the whole abortion thing
that was brought to light today um has
kind of
not like i mean obviously he made a good
case i understand that when you're
trying to play around with the vote i'm
running out of time that's really
interesting thank you all for talking to
us tonight now back to you jane
thanks very much tomorrow well uh let's
have a final chat with our deputy
political editor sam coates so sam this
is the last of the big official
discussions with the media and these two
candidates where does it leave us in
this campaign well i think tonight we
really got a sense of what this race is
about look to characterize it it was
mr sensible versus the disruptor the
traitor versus the boris johnson
loyalist predictable versus
unpredictable look as we saw from the
show of hands at the end of that debate
rishi sunak won the room he was probably
smoother but there were also more
challenges there were more
nervous moments i thought with liz trust
her inability sometimes to explain to
apologize to characterize why she's
ended up doing what she's done damaged
her amongst the people that looked up
close but all the way through this race
people in the conservative party have
been weighing up what rishi sunac did in
government and how he behaved at the end
versus liz trust just the view i think
of boris johnson amongst many of the
conservative party membership their
enduring fondness for him still plays a
big place and has a big place in this
leadership contest
sam thanks very much well what an
interesting evening it has been that is
all from us here in this studio after a
special program on the battle for number
10 where we heard that liz truss said
the predicted recession is not
inevitable she wouldn't apologize to
nicolas sturgeon whilst rishi sunak won
over the sky news audience julian
joseph's coming up next with lots more
analysis